CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: So I feel
that an introduction for Salman
Rushdie is almost unnecessary.
Nonetheless, here we go.
We are delighted to welcome
Salman Rushdie to discuss
his 12th novel,
"Two Years, Eight
Months, and Twenty-Eight Days."
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Nights.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Nights.
Excellent start.
Anyway, it's now being 26 years,
seven months, and 28 days,
or nights, since the fatwa
against Rushdie was announced,
and 17 years in 14 days
since the government of Iran
announced a public commitment
that it would neither
support nor hinder
assassination operations.
However, it's only one of
the many stories that make up
the life of Salmon Rushdie.
He was born in Bombay
and educated there
and it Rugby School
and Warwickshire
before reading
history at Cambridge.
Before turning to
literature full time,
he worked as a
copywriter for Ogilvy,
and while there he wrote a
small book that some of you
may have heard of called
"Midnight's Children."
This went on to win the 1981
Booker Prize for fiction,
the Booker of Bookers for the
best novels among the Booker
prize winners for fiction
at its 25th anniversary,
and finally the
best of the Bookers,
awarded to commemorate the
prize's 40th anniversary.
He's completed 12 novels, two
children's books, and a memoir
along with three edited
collections and other essays
and works of nonfiction.
He's an emblem of
and strong proponent
shouting for human rights
and freedom of speech.
He's a fellow of the Royal
Society of literature
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] and in 2007
was knighted for his services
to literature.
So again, please
welcome Salman Rushdie.
[APPLAUSE]
So we're here to talk about
your new book, "Two Years, Eight
Months, and
Twenty-Eight Nights."
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Which is 1,001.
I know you're a very
mathematical audience,
but as the internet
already tells me,
it doesn't work if
there's a leap year.
[LAUGHTER]
To which all I can say
is there's no leap year.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: So in a
recent interview in Canada,
where I'm from, you said
in reference the tails,
the "1,001 Nights"
and other myths
that realism showed up later in
your life and seemed inferior.
So it would be
great if you could
start by telling us a
little bit about the djinn
in this particular novel.
What brought you to the
djinn and their stories
as a way of grounding a much
larger cultural narrative
or battle?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: If
you grow up in India,
you grow up with the djinn.
They're everywhere.
People will still use
them colloquially.
If you're car has a flat tire,
you say that a djinn did it.
If you knock over
a glass of wine,
it's always somebody
else's fault.
It may as well be a
supernatural creature.
So these stories are things
that you grow up with,
and the djinn-- basically
they're quite mischievous.
On a scale, they range
from ordinary mischief
to something much
more malevolent.
So I'd had them in
the back of my head,
and when I found
myself wanting to write
a novel about a world in
which things were going badly
wrong in many ways, it seemed
that these creatures whose job
it was to make things
go very badly wrong
seemed like an obvious
metaphor to reach for.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: But as
creatures they also-- Dunya,
the princes of the djinn.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: I'm assuming
that there are nice ones,
but I said basically
made them up.
Yes, I suppose the main
female character of the novel
is a princess of the djinn
who is unlike the others--
somebody who is actually very
fond of human beings in general
and one in particular.
And when her less pleasant
fellow djinn attack the earth,
she's the one who
comes to the defense.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Oh,
and she comes out swinging.
It's not just a little
bit of a defense.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yeah,
she's a badass creature.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
So in the novel,
she rallies here descendants.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yes,
because she's been here--
the story suggests
that hundreds of years
ago in the 12th century
she visited the earth
and had a love affair
with an Arab philosopher
and produced
supernatural numbers
of children, which
gradually over the centuries
coming down to the present day
had spread across the world.
And when there's this assault
on the earth by the dark djinn,
she comes back and
sort of, as it were,
reactivates her
descendants, who in some way
are partly djinn as well
in order to fight back.
So it's a sort of war of
the worlds story, I guess.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
And so one of the things
I found very interesting was
this supernatural epic battle
that takes place at the
climax, and on the one hand,
we seem to have reason and on
the other faith or religion.
Do you think there's
any way of finding
a common ground
between those two,
or are we destined to fight?
Is there a synthesis
or just a battle?
SALMAN RUSHDIE:
Are you asking me?
I think no.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: But then
what do we do in response?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Excuse me?
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: What
do we do if there's--
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Oh,
I think we can just
start understanding that
the real fairytale is God
and get rid of it.
I'm very much of the
Christopher Hitchens persuasion
in this matter, who is
one of my close friends,
and so we agree about
the fact that religion
has become a very big
problem in the world,
and it's very
strange because when
I was young-- I mean in the
mid '60s when I was a college,
nobody ever talked
about religion.
Religion just sort
of disappeared.
The idea that it would return
to become a colossal force
in the world would have
seemed absurd 15 years ago,
and yet there it is, sitting
in the middle of the room.
And so even though
I'm not particularly--
I'm not at all a
religious person--
I find myself writing
about it quite a lot,
because it seems to me
there's no way of not
writing about it
because it becomes
such an important subject.
So I would really like never
to write about it again.
That would be my preference.
In fact, I've kind
of promised myself
that the next book will have
no mention of religion in it,
but I've been saying this
to myself for a long time,
and I keep failing.
So there we are.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
So is it religion
is a grand narrative that
draws you back, or did--
SALMAN RUSHDIE: No, it's just
because of its public function
these days, and I think--
because my view is that I
haven't-- the private practice
of religion in my view is not
my business.
If there are people who
find it valuable to them,
nourishing, consoling, whatever,
that's just not my business.
That's their business,
and it's only
when it becomes a
public force, when
it starts telling other people
how to behave or trying to,
then I think it becomes
everyone's business,
and that's sort of
what's happened.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: One of
the things we like to do is--
SALMAN RUSHDIE: By
the way, just to say
that the point about the djinn--
one of the things I really
like about them is
that they're pre--
they do exist in the
Islamic tradition,
but they're actually
pre-Islamic.
They're actually
ancient pagan creatures,
and one of the things
I like about them
is that quite a lot of
them don't necessarily
believe in God either.
So to them God is just as weird
an idea as the djinn are to us,
and that made them
appealing to me.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
We certainly
see that in this epic
clash between the two sides
that you have on
the one hand you
have Dunya, who is
fighting for humanity
and is trying to save humanity,
which she successfully does,
but on the other,
you say, oh well,
if that's what
you'd like us to do.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: The
problem with the djinn
is that one of them
in the novel gets
kind of infected with
religion, but most of them
just want to cause
trouble and take over,
and they're actually
not very good at it,
because the thing
about the djinn
is that they are
very bad at focusing.
They have a sort of form of ADD.
They get bored easily.
They get distracted.
So even when they're trying
to conquer the world,
they decide, well,
maybe not today.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Or
there's the scene where the sea
creature emerges over the Staten
Island ferry, and it has a nap.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: They have
these metamorphic abilities,
so they can turn themselves
into all kinds of things,
and one of them
turns into a monster
and eats the Staten Island
ferry, I'm sorry to say.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: But
then he has a nap, right?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Huh?
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
Then he has a nap.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Then
he has a nap, exactly.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: That
takes a couple of months.
So it's quite
interesting to see even
in the midst of this battle.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: They're lazy.
The djinn are very
lazy, which is useful,
because it makes
them defeatable.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
And one of the things--
they're fantastic creatures.
So one of the things
we learn in the novel
is that stories are a curse
and the antidote at the same,
nested inside each other.
This is the climax of the book,
and I found this incredible
that we can't pull them apart.
We can't see where they
start, see where they end.
They're nested together.
So what do you think the
place for stories is?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: You see, the
reason for that-- first of all,
there is in the tradition in
books like the "1,001 Nights"--
those books are very fond of
the idea of the nested stories
and Chinese box stories, a story
in which somebody says that
reminds me of a story, and tells
you a story in which somebody
says there's a story
about that, and so on.
So that's there
in the literature,
but it struck me
that in many ways--
and many of those
stories don't finish.
They get interrupted,
and it seemed to me
in many ways that's quite a
true portrait of how we live,
that we all live-- we are
ourselves an unfinished story,
because here we are being
the story of ourselves,
and surrounding us
like concentric circles
of continuing stories.
So there's, let's say, the
story of our family and friends
around us, and
around that there's
a larger story of community,
and maybe the story of a city,
or the story of a
country, or et cetera.
So we are there in the middle
of these concentric circles
of stories, and
they're not ended.
They're continuing.
So we all live in these
unfinished stories,
and so I thought that was
just a useful way of talking
about what life is like.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: And I love
the metaphor-- an indigenous
writer have read for my own
research in the past talks
about these concentric
circles of stories,
but they intersect
as well, right?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: And
they intersect as well.
They infect each other.
A wonderful example
of this is-- I
didn't know how many
of you have seen--
there's a wonderful film by
Pedro Almodovar called "Talk
to Her," and in that film,
he does this, where somebody
starts telling a story, and
the film goes into that story,
and in that story
there's another story,
and it goes down
about five levels.
And then they all end, one after
the other, boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, like that.
And it's an amazing effect,
and he does it with such skill
that you're never confused.
You know exactly where
you are, but it's
a very appealing
thing, and I had--
there's a chapter in the book
where the stories start diving
into other stories,
and it was one
of the more difficult
chapters to write
because you want
the reader to still
have a sense of a through line.
There's a reason
why you're doing it,
but it was also one of the
most fun chapters to write.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
Yeah, it was.
I very much enjoyed it.
Before we open it
up to the audience,
we have a few crowdsourced
questions, and a lot of them
not surprisingly
were about religion.
So what one was,
what can be done
to ensure religion is not
being taken literally,
and do you believe our--
SALMAN RUSHDIE: What can I
do that religion is not what?
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
Being taken literally.
And do you believe our own
political correctness prevents
us from tackling
the problem head on?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Well,
what can be done
is to-- I think that two
parts of the question
are related, because it seems
to me the way you confront
ideas that you don't
like is to confront them
and argue about them.
And there has grown up
a conventional wisdom
that somehow religion
should be excused
from that kind of criticism,
and frankly I don't see why.
It seems to me that's it's
one idea amongst many ideas,
and one of the-- kind
of a central part
of the nature of
intellectual life
is to question all
ideas, to submit them
to a rigorous interrogation,
particularly when
you begin to see that they're
capable of giving rise
to very unpleasant effects.
So yeah, I do think there
is a problem of PC where
people are-- and I
don't think it's only
political correctness.
I think it's also
fear, because there
have been a number
of, as you know,
violent attacks on people who
have been critical of religion.
That, again, makes people
worried about doing it,
but I think it's very
important to do it.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
And it also ignores
centuries of religious
philosophical tradition, right?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yeah.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
We have centuries
of arguing about religion--
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Exactly.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: --in
good constructive ways.
SALMAN RUSHDIE:
Yeah, and there's
one thing about-- there's two
ways of arguing about religion.
One is from inside, and
the other is from outside.
So of course all religions
have theological disputes
and evolve in a
way through that,
but it's also important
to be able to come
at the subject from
outside so that you don't
have to be bound by the
rules of the religion,
because I think
one of the problems
of the interior argument
is that you can't really
question first principles.
You can't question
the existence of God.
You can't question the
nature of revelation,
and it seems to
me that, if you're
going to really
talk about religion,
you have to question
both those things.
But I think both forms of
discourse have their place,
yes.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
Another related question,
which I'll touch on
because I quite liked it,
but I think you might
have answered most of it.
A new term has been coined
recently, regressive leftists,
to identify a trend where
liberal theocratic ideologies
are being defended by
people through conflating
valid criticism of an
ideology with bigotry
towards individuals.
So what are your thoughts on
the way that term is used?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Well, I
hadn't heard the term,
but I kind of like it.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
[INAUDIBLE].
SALMAN RUSHDIE: I do think
it has-- I found myself
saying this to
somebody the other day
that what other ideology
that was aggressively
anti-woman, homophobic,
and antisemitic
would the British left support?
And the answer is probably
none, but for some reason
when it's a religion all
that gets brushed aside,
and I think that's a
really very big problem.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Great.
The last one for me-- it's
one of my favorite passages
in the novel.
It's where the
American president--
I love how you've
brought pop culture,
and Donald Trump is
a [INAUDIBLE] here.
It's wonderful.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: I'm very proud
of having invented Donald Trump
before he invented himself.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
I do wonder, though,
about the timing of that.
So there's a wonderful,
very subtle aside to Trump,
and I think, oh, gosh, did
you actually realize that--
SALMAN RUSHDIE: No, no.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Incredible.
Incredible.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: The
point is, if you
happen to have an
egomaniac in town,
he's going to do something
to draw attention to himself.
I didn't realize he was
going to do this, but--
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Well,
beautifully prescient
in the context of the book.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: I have this
terrible confession to make,
which is I've only met
Donald Trump like twice,
but for some reason
he took a shine to me.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is really embarrassing.
And I think it's
because a very-- this
will show you how
old we both are,
but there's once upon
a time I found myself
sitting next to him and his
children at a Crosby, Stills,
and Nash concert in New York,
and he knew all the words
to all the songs.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Oh my word.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: But
I thought, oh my god.
Donald Trump singing along
with Crosby, Stills, and Nash.
That was weird,
but somehow I think
it became-- I'm sorry to say--
a bonding experience for us.
So now-- literally I have to
say I've only met him twice
since then, but
on one occasion we
were-- I don't know-- at
some theater together,
and he's never
quiet, Donald Trump.
So he came at me from
a distance like this,
and he would shout Salman!
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Oh my word.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: You're the man!
[LAUGHTER]
And I go, really?
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: So will
this be part of the campaign?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: To which the
correct response, of course,
is no, Donald.
You're the man.
[LAUGHTER]
And then he offered me-- it was
at the time of the US Tennis
Open, and he said come and use
my box whenever you want it.
And I thought that's a kind
of real career ending move,
to be scene in Donald
Trump's box at the US Open.
The end.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Oh my.
SALMAN RUSHDIE:
On the other hand,
it's a really good box, so--
[LAUGHTER]
But I didn't go.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
Are you a tennis fan?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yeah.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
Well, then I don't know.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: No, no, no.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
Principles are important, but--
SALMAN RUSHDIE: No, no, no.
There are other places to sit.
[LAUGHTER]
Which also have a good
view, but yeah anyway,
so that's my shameful
confession-- my pal, Donald.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
It gets even better.
Yeah, so you talk
about Donald Trump.
You also talk
about Barack Obama,
and you have him
trying to respond to--
SALMAN RUSHDIE: It's
not really Barack Obama.
It's a president with big ears.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Whose wife
dances better than he does.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: His wife
That's true, but his
race is not specified,
and the actual exact time of
the novel is a little vague.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
Yes, that's true.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: So it may
or may not be Barack Obama.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
So the president
who may or may not
be Barack Obama
has to respond to all of
these strange things going on
and this war between the worlds.
There's apocalyptic storm,
and lightning strikes,
and the ground is shifting,
and people are floating,
and there's a baby that
senses corruption and causes
horrible disfigurement,
and he comes up
with this incredibly
banal response, right?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yes.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Which is
we'll continue to do everything
in our power to combat
this, and we think, well,
there's nothing
you can do at all.
This is crazy.
This is so far removed
from anything you can do.
So the question
then is really how
do we combat that which doesn't
bend to reason or rationale.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Well, that's--
the fortunate thing about being
a novelist is you get
to ask the question.
You don't have to
have the answer.
You combat it by combating it.
There isn't a magic
button, but one
of the things that the
book-- I think really what
the book suggests is
that the resistance comes
from ordinary people, because
what happens in the novel
is that these ordinary people
who discover that they're
the descendants long ago
of the djinn princess,
and so it suggests they have a
little bit of magic in them--
but what I'm really meaning
to say by that is that people
faced with an extreme
situation very often
discover in themselves
resources, courage, abilities,
which they didn't know they
possessed, and are actually
able to rise to the occasion,
and defend themselves,
and some stand up
for themselves,
and I think that's essentially
what happens in the book.
Yes, there are these
djinn flying around,
but essentially what happens
is the resistance to chaos,
mayhem, evil, et cetera is
ordinary people discovering
in themselves the
capacity to resist,
and really that's what
the book is about.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Fabulous.
With that shall we open it up
to questions from the floor?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yeah.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: There's
a microphone in the center.
Yeah, so if we could please--
I'm sure in this packed room
we've got some
excellent questions.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Or
we'll just sit here.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
I could keep talking,
but-- oh there we go.
AUDIENCE: There's a
very basic question,
which is why has there been
such a rise in religiosity?
I can remember going to
Pakistan many years ago,
and the Pakistan cricket
team would look pretty much
like everyone else.
And now people are bearded and
say [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] all
the time.
What has happened
that has caused this?
I agree with you.
I think growing up in
the '60s I would never
have predicted this outcome.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: No.
None of us-- unfortunately while
we were all busy inhaling--
[LAUGHTER]
--unlike President Clinton,
basically the uncool people
took over the world.
So beware-- this
could happen to you.
I don't know.
I think the problem
with the question
is it's a very
important question,
and the audience is
not at all short,
but because I
think what happened
is different things
in different places.
I think what
happened in Iran was
a response to the
rule of the Shah,
and what happened in
Algeria was a response
to the gradual corruption of the
party of the revolution, which
had been a secular
party, and so on.
But one of the things
I could say in general
is precisely related to what
this book talks about, which
is that we live in
a time of incredibly
metamorphic, rapid
transformation,
change everywhere.
The world is changing
at a speed faster
than it's ever done before,
and some of that is your fault,
but I think for some people,
or even for many people,
in a time of such change it
engenders great uncertainty
and even fear.
And it becomes comforting
to reach for something which
feels unchanging,
something which
says this is an eternal truth,
and you can hold on to this
and cling on to
this in the middle
of this time of great change.
And I think that's one of the
things which for some people
is an attraction--
that religion becomes
an attraction because
it seems to offer
a moral code and
an unchanging world
in the middle of a world
that is changing very fast.
So that's one thing.
The violent thing
is another thing.
That's another
conversation perhaps.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Great.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Salman.
Thank you for being
here and for being you.
I really appreciate someone
stepping up like this.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My
question is you said
people can think in their
own homes what they want,
and at the risk of trying
to combat thought crime,
I wonder if that's the right
attitude because religions
are so inherently damaging.
OK, it's fine to at your home
believe the Christian mythology
or the Muslim
mythology, but to do
that, you have to accept a
certain set of tenants that
are very worrying,
because, yeah,
like you said, being scared
of gay people and those kinds
of things-- in Holland,
for example, we
have Christian
parties, and if they
were to come to power
as an absolute power,
I'm worried that they
will have to follow what
it says in the
Bible, and suddenly
all those people
that are silent might
have to own up to that belief.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yeah.
Well, look, it's a
well asked question
because private life is not
necessarily only private.
Private life can
lead to public action
and to the kinds of
prejudice and bigotry
that you touched on.
I suppose what I
was trying to say
is that the moment it becomes
any form of a public action,
which can include a prejudice
against a gay person,
for example, then it
becomes a real difficulty,
and we have to talk about it.
And I'm just saying
that there are
people, who are not
fanatics, who are not
bigots, who are religious.
And we live in the country
the Church of England.
It's the only religion
ever started for a divorce.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's a relatively mild
form of a religion, which
in other forms can
be quite virulent,
such as in America
nowadays, where
there are very virulent
forms of Christianity.
I'm just saying that
the private desire
to find a form of consolation--
I might think it's wrong.
I might think it's
absurd, but in the end,
it's not my business to tell you
what you should believe or not
believe, but the moment that
belief starts manifesting
itself in society in ways
to become problematic,
then of course it is my
business, and your business,
and everyone else's.
So I'm just trying to
make a distinction,
but I agree it's a
difficult distinction
to make between private
life and public life.
And actually it's one
of the things that
would argue with
Christopher Hitchens
about, because he would
take your position, which
is all of it is awful, and you
can't make these hairsplitting
distinctions.
And I'm tempted
by that position.
I'm just trying to be nice.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: I
also-- I have to wonder.
Certain aspects of
religion seem good, right?
Charity, for example.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yeah, certain
aspects of religion seem good,
but you could be charitable
without being religious.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Very true.
I
SALMAN RUSHDIE: You could be
good without being religious.
I think it's one of
the things that I
find most problematic about the
way in which religious people
talk-- is that there's an
assumption that you can't have
an ethical sense if you don't
have a religious structure,
and you don't have some kind
of supreme arbiter, and so on.
It seems to me quite clear
that the opposite is true,
that human beings in some
sense have an ethical sense,
and one of the ways in
which historically we've
given expression to
that ethical sense
is to create religions which
codify a form of ethics.
It seems to me that
religions exist historically
to answer two great questions.
One is, how did we get here?
Where do we come from?
And the other is, now that
we're here, how shall we live?
So the question of
origins, the question
of ethics-- it seems to me
those are the big questions.
And my view is we know
a lot more now than we
knew when the Bible was written,
and one of things we know
is that, at least
in my view, I don't
need to look at
religion for an answer
to the question of origins.
It seems to me
there are a lot more
interesting and knowledgeable
answers than that available
now, and I don't want to look
at religion for an answer
the question of ethics,
because on the whole,
religion has not
been particularly
great on that subject of late.
And so my requirement
for religion
doesn't exist, because I
don't need it to answer
these great questions of life.
And I think it's
perfectly possible
to argue that our
ethical sense precedes
our development of
religions and the we
are in some way
hardwired to have
an-- I think people do
instinctively have a need
to distinguish right from
wrong and good action
from bad action, and religion is
just one of the codes by which
they try to explain that.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
Next question, please?
AUDIENCE: Hi, [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you very much
for taking the time
to come in and speak to us.
I see a lot of
value in religion,
and from all of
the things you've
mentioned already, providing
some truth in an ever changing
world, fighting
against capitalism--
but I don't want to
ask about capitalism.
I want to ask about the
concerning effects of religion
as we see them today.
If you follow the
Middle East, or Europe,
or, as matter of fact,
unfortunately almost anywhere,
you can see those
bad circumstances.
And I would like to ask
you if you are an optimist,
and if you are, why?
And if you're a pessimist, why?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Well, it's very
difficult to look at the world
right now and not have
a tragic sense of life
if you're a writer.
However, this book is
strangely optimistic,
you will discover as
you go through it.
It's perhaps more optimistic
than the times deserve,
but what I think is
quite seriously that-- I
was a student of history.
That was my university
subject, and one
of the things you learn
in the study of history
is the unpredictability
of history,
the idea that history inevitably
goes in a certain direction
is just not true, that history
is very, very changeable
and unpredictable,
and it constantly
takes one by surprise.
Just to give you one recent
example, if I had been sitting
here in January of 1989
and I had said to you
the Soviet Union will not
exist at Christmas time,
you would have
thought I was crazy
because it seemed to be this
huge, solid, powerful entity
that was just there.
The idea that it would
just blow away like dust
was very hard to imagine,
and yet that's what happened,
but of course now
there's somebody
trying to put it back together,
but that's a different story.
I'm just saying that it's an
example of how unexpectedly
and rapidly things can shift.
And so I think if one
wants to be-- they
can shift for the worse,
as well, by the way.
Not just for the
better, but what I think
is the future is
invariably unexpected.
It's not what we think
it's going to be.
It could be worse than we
think it's going to be,
or it could be better, but
it's going to be different,
and so I think that's
a kind of comfort,
the mutability of the future.
And I think nowadays
there's so many people
whose job appears to be
trying to predict the future.
Futurology has become
this big thing,
and it always strikes
me that futurology
is the science of being wrong
about the future, because just
look at the way in which the
future has been described
in movies quite recently.
The future according to
"2001 A Space Odyssey"--
in that future, we're all
wearing Pierre Cardin jump
suits, and actually space
exploration is really much more
advanced than it is,
and as it happens,
we're not wearing Pierre
Cardin jump suits.
I can't see anyone,
and we haven't really
got as far as the movie
suggests we might have got
in terms of leaving the planet.
So every time anybody tries
to predict the future,
it never works.
It actually tells
you about that time.
The reason why
George Orwell called
"1984" "1984" is because
it was written in 1948.
He just flipped the
last two digits,
but the 1984 that he
wrote about is much more
a portrait of fears that
were present in 1948.
It tells us a lot about the time
in which the book was written,
and I think that's-- when
people project into the future
in works of art, whether
movies, or books, or et cetera,
they're actually talking
about their own concerns.
And actually one of the
things about this book, which
somebody actually explicitly
says in the book--
that if you're talking
about the future,
you're talking
about the present.
If you're talking
about the past,
you're talking
about the present,
because we are here now, and
we have our concerns now.
And we find those concerns
either in the past
or in the future.
That's how we think.
So if you look at, for
instance, histories--
if you take the 16th century--
I guess since Hilary Mantel so
much popularized the
16th century of late,
but if you look at the way
in which the 16th century was
written about, in the 17th
century, the 18th century,
the 19th century,
and the 20th century,
they could be writing
about different times
entirely because each
age finds in the past
the things that concern
it in its present.
And the same is
true of the future,
so I think the only-- to answer
your question about optimism,
all I can say is it
won't be what you think.
It might be worse.
It might be better, but it
won't be what you think--
the day after tomorrow, I mean.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
That's quite
a solid scientific outcome.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Huh?
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: It's
a solid scientific outcome.
We know what it will not be.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: We know
what it will not be.
Exactly.
That's very good.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Fabulous.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: What you
think it's going to be
is what it won't be.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Fabulous.
Next question, please?
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
It's been almost 30
years since you received
what can only be described
as a very bad book
review from the Ayatollah.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: It was
described as that--
[LAUGHTER]
--by V.S. Naipaul.
AUDIENCE: Oh really?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yes, it was.
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering,
based on the Britain of today,
do you think that your
rough years that followed
would be easier in the
Britain of today or harder,
given various shifts in public
discourse, moral relativity?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: No, I think
it would be much worse now.
I think I was actually quite
fortunate that what happened--
I would, on the whole,
not recommend it,
but I think that was
just before, for example,
the explosion of the
information universe.
And I think now information
moves so fast, and as we know,
the internet is a very
regrettably good tool
for hostility.
It's for many things,
but including that.
There's all kinds
of hysterias that
seem to sweep
across the internet,
and I think the danger
would have been much greater
is what I'm saying,
because I think
it would be impossible to
magnify the attack 1,000
fold, 10,000 fold.
I also just think the world's
become even more violent
than it was then,
and if you like,
the kind of
privatization of violence
has made it more unpredictable
when the violence will occur.
At that time, the
danger arose essentially
from the Iranian
state and its proxies,
and essentially
from nobody else,
although the Iranians did
try and involve other people,
but really nobody wanted
to know about truthfully.
We've also made it fixable,
because basically there's
one player.
You can find ways to
talk to that person
and to nullify it, which is
eventually what happened.
Now the threat is everywhere,
and random, et cetera,
and that's more alarming.
So I think people are more
afraid now than they were then,
and it's a very much more
worrying time for that reason.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Fabulous.
AUDIENCE: Have you
got time for one more?
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
Of course we do.
We actually have time for quite
a-- well, a few more anyway.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yeah, more.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Yeah, yeah.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: More, more.
AUDIENCE: One of the
things which I particularly
enjoyed in this session
actually is being exposed
to your critical thinking
and the way you break down
your problems and look at them.
I have a 15-year-old
son, and I'm
very struck by the lack
of the critical thinking
that they get taught at school.
It's very much here's
a bit of rote learning.
Go and learn this.
And as a result as
a nation, we seem
to be happier debating
the offside rule
than we are questions
such as, why am I here,
and how should I live?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Well, the
offside rule is very important.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: What should
we be promoting,
and how can we get
people to be having
these important discussions?
SALMAN RUSHDIE:
Well, I think this
is a question for the
school curriculum.
I think you're right that
people are not really
encouraged to think.
It's interesting you raise the
subject of critical thinking.
I have an 18-year-old son who
has just started at university,
and he's very
philosophically inclined,
which means that he
likes to argue a lot.
[LAUGHTER]
And of course believes
that he's always correct.
And he told me
yesterday on the phone
that they had been asked
in this philosophy class
to come up with a definition
of what a human being is.
Not specific to a particular
country, or culture,
or whatever, but what is it
that makes us human beings as
opposed to not human beings.
And somebody in the class had
said that critical thinking was
one of the things the
defined us as human beings,
and then being
18-years-old, he went on
to argue that therefore,
if you're in a coma,
you probably no longer
qualify as a human being
because you can't indulge
in critical thinking.
The person clearly
didn't understand
the flaw in that argument,
and so my son rather
proudly told me that he'd
really taken him down
because he pointed out that
actually when we're asleep
we're not capable of
critical thinking,
and so do we cease to be
human beings when be sleep.
To which the other
young fellow didn't
have an answer, so my son wins.
[LAUGHTER]
The point is I think it's
very helpful and valuable
to young people to be asked to
have that kind of conversation,
however unsophisticated
the arguments might be.
You can only acquire
sophisticated arguments
by getting there, by learning,
and I certainly benefited,
I think, in my education
by having philosophy
as a part of what I studied,
and ideas, the history of ideas,
as something that
I studied, and I
think it would be really
valuable if people were
asked to study those things.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: Why do you feel
that other people don't
seem to think it's important?
Is there a malaise
in this country?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Because there's
an idea around at the moment--
which is frankly not specific
to any political party,
so it's not a kind of
left right argumen--
that education is a training
for a job, the kind of market
driven idea of education that
basically you're channeling
people towards the
workplace, and that's
what you're doing at
school or at college.
Whereas the old idea of
the liberal arts education,
the liberal education, was that
you're actually training people
to be human beings
and allowing them
to emerge from the educational
system as complicated,
interesting, rounded
human beings,
who will then do something
valuable in the world.
And I think that idea
is under threat now.
Not just in England,
but everywhere, and I
think it's a very valuable idea,
and it needs to be restated.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Nice.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
Next question?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I thought it was
very interesting--
I study history
myself, and what you're
talking about the
unpredictability of history
and especially about how we are
how different centuries were
viewed and had different
interpretations of history.
In terms of the
role of a novelist,
how do you think
that has changed,
or has it actually stayed
as almost that kind
of stable source of
truth or questioning?
It's got to be quite interesting
to see you opinion on that.
SALMAN RUSHDIE:
Well, of course you
see the problem with
the moment anybody
says something like the role of
the novelist it doesn't apply.
There's no answer which
applies across the board
because novelists are of
very, very different kinds.
Some feel the need to
have a kind of public art,
an art that engages with
public life, and others don't.
They just don't want to, and
I think both kinds of novels
can be great.
So I'm reluctant ever to say
here is what writers should do,
but I think what literature does
do at its best is to provide
a world for people to live
in while they're reading
the book, which is first of
all interesting in itself,
enjoyable in itself, and
secondly makes the reader think
about human nature, understand
things about how we are
with each other and what
we do to each other,
and to come out of that
world with perhaps a slightly
enhanced sense of what it
is to live in this world.
And I think that's what
writing does at its best,
and I think one of
the things I think
is a kind of magical thing about
literature as opposed to film,
or music, or whatever is that
the other art forms happen
outside you.
You sit there as an
audience, and there's
somebody playing a musical
instrument over there,
or there's a movie on
a screen over there.
And you watch it, and you can
engage with it very deeply--
of course you can-- and be
very deeply affected by it,
but it's over there,
and you're over here.
Whereas when you
read a book, it's
inside your head, and the
intimacy of the conversation
between the writer
and the reader--
the conversation that
happens inside the reader
is a very profound
intimacy, and it's
a unique thing to
literature that it
can be an interior experience.
And so when books
affect you, they
affect you very profoundly,
and I think the experience
of falling in love with a
book, of really loving a book,
which may not happen that
often-- it may happen
a few times in a lifetime.
If you have to name
the books-- if somebody
asks you what are the
books you really love,
that's probably not a long list.
It's probably a short
list, but those books, I
believe, in some way change
the way you see the world,
that you begin afterwards
to see the world
a little bit through what you've
absorbed from that work of art.
And I think that's how-- I
don't believe in this idea
that literature can
change the world.
I think that's kind
of over claiming.
Every so often,
very rarely there's
a work of literature that
has a direct social impact,
and one example of that would
be "Uncle Tom's Cabin"-- that
when that book came out,
it had a profound impact
on the discussion of
slavery in America,
and in fact there's
a rather nice story
that President Lincoln was
introduced to Harriet Beecher
Stowe, the author of
"Uncle Tom's Cabin,"
and he said to her, so
you're the little woman
who started this big war.
And you can see the sense
in which that's true,
but mostly that's
not what happens.
Mostly what happens is
this other strange thing
of every so often this
intimate experience
between the writer and reader
doing something profound
to the reader.
And the great thing about it
is that neither the author
nor the reader can predict
when it's going to happen
or to whom.
AUDIENCE: Do you that's
a timeless experience?
So no matter what's
going on in the world,
no matter how
history is changing
and how people are changing,
society is changing,
do you think that's an
experience that [INAUDIBLE].
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yeah,
I think that's what--
this is why this form
has hung around so long.
It's because our desire
to be told stories
is very, very central
to human nature.
I've said often that we are
the storytelling animal.
We are the only
creature on earth
that does this very strange
thing of telling itself
stories in order to understand
what kind of creature it is.
Some of those stories
are true stories.
Some of them are
made up stories,
but we all tell
each other stories.
I'm not even talking about
professional writers.
We all tell each other stories
about ourselves all the time,
and it's a way in which
we understand who we are.
And I think therefore we
are creatures who understand
ourselves through narrative.
That's the point
I'm trying to make.
We have more narrative oriented
than analysis oriented.
We learn more
through stories than
through any other structure,
and that's why it persists.
It's just something people need.
When children are very
little, the moment
they feel safe,
and loved, and fed,
and housed-- very, very soon
after that the next question
is tell me a story.
The desire for once upon a
time is very, very, very deep
in human beings, and so no
matter what else happens,
that persists.
People still want it.
Tell me a story.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
I think one thing that
strikes me about that is data.
So we're a very
data driven company,
but data is just another
story or a set of stories.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yeah, I think
we just organize ourselves
through narrative.
I think it's natural
to us to do it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Salman.
Massive fan.
Read all your books, and I
guess that's because someone
born in India and growing up
in the west your novels were
always able to bring
together these really
unrelated spheres in my life.
And my question for you is
quite a general one really.
If you had any thoughts
on the future of India,
its role in the world, and its
relationship with the west?
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Well, god.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI:
A nice easy to finish.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yeah, in
30 words or less, right?
I think it's a worrying time in
India, particularly in the area
we're talking about
tonight, which
has to do with free expression.
I think there's a lot
of bullying going on,
a lot of repression.
There's been three people
killed in recent weeks
for upsetting various extremist
groups, writers included.
So it's becoming this
government has allowed
a kind of thugishness to
arrive in Indian life which
has never been there
to that degree before.
Of course, there have been
terrible violent moments
in the history of India.
It would be wrong not to
say that, but right now--
it's very interesting that after
these recent murders, including
the murder of this Muslim
man for having allegedly
eaten beef, which it turns
out he actually hadn't done,
but even if he had, so what?
That's not a reason to lynch
somebody, except now it is.
And since this happened,
and since there
have been these other
murders recently of writers
and other anti-government
individuals,
the prime minister of
India has said nothing,
and Mr. Modi is an
incredibly talkative man.
He talks all the time about
everything, particularly
himself.
He's a kind of
Donald Trump figure,
except he's running the country
with a very large majority.
Very, very powerful.
Probably the most
powerful leader that India
has had for quite a
long time because he
doesn't require coalitions.
He doesn't require compromises.
He's there with a
mandate, and yet here
are these terrible
events happening
with what seems to be at
the very least the collusion
of members of his party, if
not the actual organization
of the events by
members of his party.
We don't quite know that yet,
but it seems fairly clear
that the BGP people
have been involved
in all these atrocities,
and yet not a word
from the prime
minister's office,
which is clearly
saying, go ahead.
It's clearly enabling
giving permission, unspoken
permission, to these
very violent elements
in the society.
So yeah, I'm very
worried about it.
I'm very worried
about it, and whenever
people speak up--
right now there's
an enormous protest
going on in India
by writers and
intellectuals, many of whom--
because the Indian Academy,
the [INAUDIBLE] Academy,
has also remained
completely silent
in the face of the
actual murders of writers
and intellectuals.
Hasn't said a single thing,
and so an enormous number,
a growing number-- it's
seven today-- of writers
and intellectuals
are returning honors
that they've received
from the academy
and protesting
against its silence.
And immediately
they are vilified
because the thing about
the Modi crew, let's say,
is that it's enormously
skilled at using social media.
I had a tweet this morning
supporting some of the writers
who had protested
about these things.
There have now been
maybe 10,000 tweets
calling me all sorts of
names within a couple
hours of my saying
this one thing,
and that's happening to
everybody who in any way
objects to what's going on.
There's an orchestrated very,
very extreme attack on them
throughout all media.
So yeah, it's a worrying time.
I think you're
getting to the point
where it's difficult to
call India a free society.
I think they may just
have elected Mussolini.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Great.
I think we have time for
one more very fast question,
and then we'll move to books
are for sale and a book signing
outside, but if we could
take one last quick one.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
This is on a slightly
lighter note.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Yes.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Oh good.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: If you can choose
what's your favorite book
that you've written.
SALMAN RUSHDIE:
That I've written?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, also what's the
favorite one that you've read,
assuming they're not the same.
[LAUGHTER]
SALMAN RUSHDIE: I
don't actually read
the novels of Salman Rushdie.
I just write them.
By the time I
finished writing them,
I've read them so many
times that I never
want to look at them again,
because in the process
of writing a book, you reread,
and reread, and reread.
And by the time the book has
gone through the publication
period, you read it again in
great detail dozens of times,
and at the end of
that, I'm done with it.
I have to say I'm really
delighted with the way
in which this book is
being received so far.
People seem to be really
enjoying it and having
a great time with it, and
that's a very nice feeling.
And there are these
two earlier books
that I wrote for my two sons
when they were 11 or 12 years
old each, "Haroun and
the Sea of Stories,
and "Luka and the Fire of Life,"
which one is the sort of sequel
to the other.
And I have a very
soft spot for those,
partly because they were written
in this very personal way,
and again, partly because I just
had the most fun writing them.
They were really--
I can see why people
who write children's books
go around looking happy,
because it's kind of fun.
And also the response you
get from young readers
is incredibly enjoyable.
I get these letters from
entire classrooms who've
been reading
"Haroun," or "Luka,"
and they've all done
drawings of the characters.
And they write me notes saying
which characters they like,
and which ones they
don't like, and giving me
tips for how to write sequels,
what that should be about.
It's really a lot of fun.
I had this letter
from a girl in America
in Massachusetts when
"Haroun" came out,
and she asked me
various questions.
She was obviously quite a
smart, highly literate reader.
So she had a quite intelligent
letter, and at the end of it,
it said, please write back.
Please reply to
this letter at once.
[LAUGHTER]
She said, because
when I grew up,
I intend to be either a writer
myself or a world leader.
[LAUGHTER]
I thought right
back to this girl.
She's going to be
president in 20 years time.
So anyway, those books,
I think, I would choose.
If I had to choose,
I would choose those
just because it's been so
much fun to be their author
because of what's
come back at me.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Fantastic.
Thank you very much for coming
here and talking to us today.
This has been an absolutely
amazing, amazing event.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Thank you.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: We're
absolutely delighted.
SALMAN RUSHDIE: Thank
you all for coming.
CHRISTINA MATTEOTTI: Please join
me in thanking Salman Rushdie.